ich habe eine menge gemacht ich meine
gerade alles kaputt nein nein ich bin
zwar programms tv mit dabei sind mit
kraft und der liebe petri dom ich bin
wieder da wo galaxy und wir haben es
tatsächlich einen plan gemacht was
falsch beziehen wird
ja wir suchen essen und überleben dieses
überleben müssen jetzt dick
unterstreichen über die also ich könnte
es easy sterben halt doch spaß weil die
letzte frage nicht gesehen unbedingt
einen kunden einfach bei patrick rücken
als ich will ich will mir die ein
verbessertes auch einen gucken wer bist
du denn jetzt eigentlich das durch bin
der re ist ein ende dieser dunkelgrünen
zauberhut auf und ich bin jetzt in einer
klaren töten sie mich hier guck guck ich
war nur schafe
bitte bitte kommt zur irischen konditors
bei dieser brücke da bitte hier oben
hier essen jungs im alter von sieben und
damit die betten machen könnte conti
bist du das ding die finger aus ich will
da durch anwalt reden manchmal siehst
mich dem regnerischen kann die post noch
nicht sehen halte ich sehe x serie a mit
dass ein halbes bitte ich fühle mich und
ich will dass ein bisher galt das ist
richtig das ist richtig schwer da jetzt
wieder gut eine million sondern mache
ich immer sein doch er macht doch petric
ich muss mich regen
gbp ist dass man das produkt thema
wirklich rein
ich muss mich schon wenn jetzt noch lose
wie so frage ich euch überhaupt wie
mache ich das mit dem scheiß trägt mit
dem krieg geschickt aber trägt erst mal
ein bisschen angst haben zusammen schon
wieder sein wie sie das machen
beim du musst mir daher lassen wir gehen
aber in die höhle wo wir eine fledermaus
für mich gefunden aber ich glaube so
kommen wir nicht weiter kommt für mich
für mich weil sie schnell wollte man
meine medien sehen die minions diese
alles arbeiten für dich bist du
hallo
mit dem was ist denn los mit dir
das mache ich hier manchmal brauchen wir
aber auch ein bisschen mit ok möchte
heroin versorgt ist dann trifft das auch
jetzt gemacht wo bleiben die jetzt
bewegt unterwegs woher wissen möchte ich
bin wenn du gerade ausgeht dass eine
schlucht ja super werde ich auch jetzt
papa ich suche erst mal ihr sterbt
manchen stellen steuert auch gestorben
also denke ich dass peter das stück der
suche ist für mich eine maus bericht zu
dem was findest du wenig schlaf
schrecken sein
sie fangen an ja jetzt mal zu ich gehe
da nicht rein
daher nun das drache hatte den
stadträten galaxy von goethe
ich habe in einem engen böse gemacht ob
ich meine gerade alles kaputt nein nein
nein nein statt das wasserstoff das
wasser habe ich es fließt ja trotzdem
normal dass jeder mussten kunden nein
der war keine fehler macht muss man
animal alles sieht's mit dir sind
vertritt was weg halte mich da muss man
da und dann wasser ja doch immer ganz
viele teams mit oder tötet schweine oder
macht irgendwas aber sterblich schweine
holen und so was zu essen weil es sehr
sehr wichtig ja ich mal petra schumann
irgendwie beschäftigung ja ja ich weiß
aber wie kommt man jetzt welches nach
delta wieder wild wie komme ich dahin
alters zu essen was ich viele dahin
kommt ich bin immer gestorben
fliegen alter
man kann fliegen aber irgendwie wollte
ich verstehe auch gar nicht warum er so
viel glück hatten und gerade eben
tatsächlich noch einige kunden haben die
zwei selten habe ich das gefühl hier
jetzt mal der nähe von ama kakao bohnen
essen die von den kommunisten an
kakaobohnen essen haben hall in massen
angepflanzt aber die bringen jetzt ein
bisschen ebenso für die notfall die kann
man nicht einfach so bündchen immer mit
masters wundervoll jan im alles mit was
du irgendwie pflanzen kannst einen namen
unter meinem haus veltrup sagt so angst
wenn ich dann immer wieder auf den wir
hier in den isarkanal aus der fraktion
komme ich einfach weg getötet ich glaube
ich mache mein feld doch noch eins
tiefer dass da quasi so unterirdisch
damals da noch ein bett hin
hey du bist du mann schützt mich ich
fliege ja durch die gegend führte
schweine superlativen von skeletten gibt
mit dem platz trainieren schwer das
schwein da bitteschön hingekommen tötet
schweine ja so viel es geht hier um in
bled mit kokosnüssen machen anpflanzen
pina colada hand pflanzen mit diesem mit
diesen machen wo kann ich ihren
anpflanzen von bäumen glaube ich und
dann was machen sie dann wachsen und
alles recht bericht biologieunterricht
der personelle und das merkt man schon
jetzt schon die zahl auf die fokussierte
ich denke man schnell immerhin ich war
ein bio kurs ich hatte auch mal bio kurs
echt meine meinung meiner hat meinen
meine minions machen nichts
die miesmuscheln mit mehr er starb auf
irgendwie mein gott ich bin besoffen was
womit ich besoffen macht mitmachen
taktik die machen jetzt machen sie da
ein bisschen was jetzt gerade sie da ein
bisschen jetzt macht ihr die kiste der
sache sei okay diese verniedlicht und
jetzt geht s einfach zur kiste und war
wahnsinnig denn die müssen mehr arbeiten
lassen muss jetzt auf dem baum
rechtsklick machen und so die
asymmetrische sammeln und ein gott ende
ich bin wegen einer verrückten ich werde
verrückt was anderes macht er sehr dick
macht jetzt das einfach jetzt passiert
und reaper ins todesstern diesem fall
sind verwundbar untergrund war minimal
zu machen kostet anfangs auch will auf
minions haben zahlt mir diesen staat
direkt mit der bus acht level wie er
reiste nie welche uni erreichen ich
frage mich überhaupt ob das ziel
erreicht werde
petra tötete einfach wieder nach
irgendwo aus dem hinterhalt
ja du hast du da auch passieren dass
dort nach afrika kopf hat der immer zu
essen gefunden oder so patrick wieder
von 1000 millionen monstern verwertet
neuen topjob de schön mehr als vertritt
schwarze schaf hier genau das macht die
katze die nach ruhig sammle gerade holz
damit ich mein haus weiter bauen kann es
sei der plan und er sammelt nahrung
ich sammle grad ich würde über marica r
hier bombardiert von macht also ich habe
einstein von der gewinner mit zwei noten
machen kann
klar wieso habe ich zweifel reicht ein
ovaler nicht das schauerliche sachen
essen machen möchte geht ok gut dann
halt einfach alle zusammen und sind
trotzdem nicht so weit wie die ganzen
anderen termins das echten stuhl
ja aber der bringt nicht weil es
eigentlich ein joby kraft stuhl und
total doof alles kriegt man halt
irgendwie nur wenn man in diesem job die
wald ist netrebko das siegel forest air
ist dieser vor ist doch mal da ist der
gast pina colada oder man wird sofort ob
das nur nachts ist hier von strawberry
ding durch die tiere genau 20 jahren
ersonnen bunten garten kosten entstehen
ihr wollt könnt mich auf 32 kokosnüsse
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch mal an
pflanzen der großanleger wie kann denn
obwohl es nur um mein gott was für die
mine hier also wo bist du eigentlich du
könntest einfach bei mir schon ins haus
kommen
ich sterbe ich das verdient
soll damit sie ein bisschen rot oder
mach ich das ganze erst einmal ein
bisschen sicherer hier oben kontakt
wieder verbaut
mal eben 23 fackeln und erwarte ich nach
ein paar geben fallen ließ nun so eisen
kupfer und verbrauch genau kupfer das
wird richtig schön das war fällig wird
kopf reisen hier ist 1 bietet ja was
hast du geschafft
ich habe es wirklich auf den schwarzen
mann eisen und kupfer zu finden und
jetzt noch ein paar updates upgrades
erosion updates dort updates raus ihre
freunde
ich weiß nicht wie ich mir das
vorgestellt hatte
irgendwie kann gibt es auch hier so
komische gerätschaft mit dem man eisen
und so schmelzen kann ja du brauchst ist
das normal
oliver reiser das heißt deshalb fehlen
gebaute hieß es das war mit felix
aufnehmen der tenniskreis main
vorbeikommen bisschen sachen machen hier
sachen macht direkt ihren wie man machen
kann kannst du so verlieh heftige sache
mitmachen
belting century lotterie controller
smelter returns mavericks
ich brauche pinke bäume dahin ist
einfach ein pinker baum auf einen
normalen baum ganz oben drauf sondern
seine pink krone wie so eine eichel auf
widerstand eventuell ein kleines
problemchen geben
das ist aber nicht das holz glaube ich
es ist verrückt sein
dafür tage skipass ist die antwort
überall
ich war aber deutlich im letter ja
nochmal obsidian für bestimmte prozesse
damals jetzt nicht scheitern aber wir
müssen da habe ich da hin um so einem
smiley zu machen und dann kann man
glaube ich aus einem eisen zwei machen
will lässt sich natürlich verändert kann
es auf jeden fall viel reisen machen
damit um viele andere coole sachen wenn
der mensch jetzt habe ich gerade gerufen
dass ein hässlicher creeper soll er
machen
jung vom ruf der diamanten
ich habe eben explosion bis hierhin
gehört
naja es war ein brief azers entscheidung
machen wir mir schnappen glaub ich da
jetzt einfach so dass da einfach ein
paar teile die einfach cool aussehen wie
er den coup was ist das aber wirklich
gar keine bedeutung
witzig 14 minuten darauf achten nicht
ich will aber immer noch so ja komm
jetzt noch das haus hier zu ende
ohne spaß ich hab gerade echt einen plan
was ich mache
so hier noch alles zu sogar kein holz
mehr klasse ich weiß ich das ist nicht
dasselbe holt nein es ist nicht dasselbe
holz dieses heute muss ich noch mal
finden dass es sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
und irgendwie auch 20 verschiedene arten
von cobblestone aber doch mit einer kann
man vernünftige sachen kräfte schon
herbei ich werde stark dafür dass wir
jetzt einfach mal sagen und seal in
dieser folge ohne einen einzigen tot
ich habe ein bisschen ein haus weiter
gebaut und sonst aber nichts geschafft
aber der nächsten folge möchte ich mir
mal ein paar waffen kräften aber dann
ohne die beiden chaoten hier ihr seid
herzlich dazu eingeladen einfach hier
irgendwas mitzumachen bei mir im haus
einfach irgendwie was zu kräften
so lange bin ich einfach alles cloud und
absicht joops ab nach den schüssen
ich habe ein bisschen eisen gemopst
sehen wir versuchen hinzukriegen
westerwald wie das weitergeht bei con
kräfte bei ihm vorbei und bei petra
natürlich auch